oh dude you gotta clean up your room  it's a complete mess I'm not coring  you're boring what's boring is me  tripping over your vines every day you  playing a little video game killing  aliens that's cool how many of you shot  in real life me upwards of several  thousand boring I think not I want to  save the galaxy with a dance-off I'm not  boring now I know how you felt just who  do you think  [Music]  you are a garden of the galaxy guardians  of the galaxy why would we be the  guardians of the galaxy the Ravagers the  sovereign  they want to take over the galaxy so  we're saving the galaxy again I see it  within you fear betrayal or any of you  do is yell at each other  Brad stupid raccoon star much you're  right we're family  Showtime a-holes  [Music]  [Applause]  beautiful  hey what about this little plant can I  smash it with a rock no it's too  adorable to care  [Applause]  [Music]